what went through your mind when you
heard the three to ten years sentence we
came in we asked as a team for five to
ten that was the maximum penalty that he
could get one that charge but to be
honest with you when he said three to
ten I was ecstatic but not only because
of the sentence but because of the
commentary that the judge gave and the
reasons why he gave that sentence not
only did he say it was a serious crime
which throughout this trial you know
because of the nature of it a lot of
things were minimized this woman andrea
constand went through so much her whole
life was turned upside down the judge
touched on that he touched on the
suffering the shame the humiliation and
everything that she experienced and so I
am very happy that he got a three to ten
but I have to be honest with you the the
best part was having the judge tell the
defendant how serious his crime was and
what it meant to the victims or to the
victim in this case what was the first
thing Andrea said to you after the
sentence was read I believe I asked her
are you happy with the sentence and she
said yes and that meant the world to me
do you think it means even more because
in 2015 when Cosby was charged
there was no me to movement the me to
movement was a very is a very powerful
movement because when you have a victim
of crime and I think it's important to
just go back to victims of crime they're
humiliated they are ashamed they are
embarrassed and they're traumatized and
that makes them less likely to report
the crime that isolation that feeling
that they won't be believed and
unfortunately you saw it with andrea
constand you see it with the Kavanaugh
accusers but let's go back to December
of 2015
Bill Cosby is charged with aggravated
indecent
the district attorney said if it weren't
for you that you all wouldn't be here
and he was saying that after the
conviction of the second trial she like
like mr. Ryan here has prosecuted
prosecuted so many sexual assaults
domestic violence cases and and she's
always stood up for victims and cos
continued to do this when you heard the
district attorney basically say you got
this ball rolling you went to Toronto
and interviewed Andrea constant and then
came back with information and said
here's what I think we need to do it
meant a lot to me because I have two
young boys I have a wonderful husband I
have a wonderful family but I put in a
lot of sacrifice as well for this case
and when I had to travel and investigate
with all of my sex cases I don't
recommend charges lightly because I
understand the stigma that can attach
when someone is charged with a crime as
serious as sexual assault
has life changed for you at all since
you know you became part of this team
that got a conviction and the second
trial I'm still a mom and that comes
first and my boys are amazing but things
have changed I went to private practice
I'm now at straddling ruinin I'm a
litigation associate there
I don't do criminal law as much anymore
but I still do practice and
substantially the same areas you played
a big role in the first trial but that
second trial the closing argument and
I'm gonna read what you said you said in
reference to this idea of a con artist
coming up you said yes you did hear
about a con you march over to Bill Cosby
you point your finger at him and you say
the perpetrator BEC con is this man
sitting right here I was just doing my
job and doing my job at that moment was
communicating to the jury why a
conviction was necessary why looking at
the evidence fairly and impartial II
could result in nothing less than three
guilty verdicts
that's what I was doing at that point if
that deposition in 2015 was not unsealed
would we be here today I don't know I
don't think so because you had a
confidentiality agreement that precluded
Andrea from going to the police she
could speak to us if we went to her but
she could not initiate contact with the
police and so I don't I don't know do
you think a case like this makes people
more likely to report sexual assault or
less likely because we've seen you know
andrea constand was kind of thrust again
into the public eye for nearly three
years I hope that it makes people more
likely to report and let me tell you why
first I hope that it showed and conveyed
a message that when you come into when
you report when you disclose you're
going to be taken with care your claims
will be investigated and justice can
prevail because at the end of the day
you're right andrea constand was
assassinated her character was
assassinated as were all of these women
but at the end of the day in that
courtroom they all stood together and
they heard the verdict and they heard
the sentence and so yeah it's a painful
process
I can't minimize that but when you have
support and you have advocates and you
know that the justice system can work I
think that makes people more likely to
report because the more the more people
who can come forward and report the less
offenders there are on the street do you
consider yourself a trailblazer I
believe that I was part of a very
important case and I had a team of
people to help me I had as I have in
many cases a very strong and courageous
victim
I had six women who were willing to put
their lives and public reputation on the
line to support a conviction so
if I were to say that I was a
trailblazer I'd have to say I was one of
many trailblazers